ne vous y trompez pas cet édifice
gothique et bien la cathédrale de
bourges c'est pourtant cette cathédrale
qui est une nouvelle fois choisi pour
incarner notre dame de paris après jean
jacques annaud venu tourner au mois de
mars notre dame brûle c'est la série
netflix notre dame la part du feu qui
prend ses quartiers ces trois statues
sont donc on peut retrouver la même
agencement à notre dame vous avez trois
statues à droite de la porte et trois
statues à gauche ici ils représentent
des prophètes la sculpture est tout à
fait intéressante extrêmement fine les
similitudes ne sont pourtant pas si
nombreuses
si les deux cathédrales ont été
construites à la même période où xiième
siècle est impulsée par les deux frères
de sully la cathédrale saint-etienne de
bourges est bien plus une cousine qu'une
véritable soeur
la différence principale à mon avis
c'est dans les arcs-boutants on se situe
donc trente ans après la construction de
notre dame de paris donc il ya une
évolution dans l' architecture dans
l'est dans les techniques
architecturales ce qui fait l'intérêt de
la cathédrale de bourges c'est que cette
cathédrale n'a pas eu à subir entre
guillemets des rénovations tout à fait
importantes comme il y a eu en
particulier à paris c'est donc la magie
du cinéma qui font de ces deux
cathédrales gothiques des jumelles et
érige la cathédrale saint-etienne au
rang de star
prenez le tournage en annoncé comme
exceptionnel donc c'est très très bien
ils s'intéressent à notre bac à tehran
on on est content sur la comparaison
n'est dans du gothique mais ces deux
cathédrales qui sont quand même très
très différentes le chevet de paris à
mon avis est beaucoup plus fin beaucoup
plus c'est de la dentelle par contre la
nef de bourges est absolument fabuleuse
cette enfilade de colonnes qui sont pas
coupés par le transept a vraiment
intérêt le tournage de la série netflix
se poursuivra jusqu'au 19 octobre et se
déclinera en six épisodes